excellent moons is is kind of a niche
topic within the discipline of
exoplanets and that's largely because
there are people I think are waiting for
those slime dunks and it was like the if
you go back to the first exoplanet
discovery that was made in 1995 by Misha
mayor and Didier colors
um I think it's true at the time that
they were seen as Mavericks that the
idea of looking for plants around Stars
was considered fringe science and you
know I'm sure many colleagues told them
why don't you do something more safe
like study eclipsing stars to binary
star systems we know those exist so why
are you wasting your time looking for
planets you're gonna get this
um alien moniker or something and you'll
be you'll be seen as a fringe Maverick
scientist and so I think it was quite
difficult for those early Planet Hunters
to get legitimacy and be taken seriously
and so very few people risked their
careers to do it except for those that
were either emboldened to try or had
maybe the career uh maybe like a tenure
or something so they didn't have to
necessarily worry about the implications
of failure and so
once that happened once they made the
first discoveries overnight
you know everyone and their dog was
gunning into exoplas and all of a sudden
the whole you know the whole astronomy
Community shifted and huge numbers of
people that were Once Upon a Time
studying eclipse and binaries you know
changed to becoming exoplank scientists
and so that was the first wave of
exoplat scientists we're now in a kind
of a second wave or in the third wave
where people like me to some degree kind
of grew up with the idea of exoplanets
as being normal you know I was 11 years
old I guess when the first exploit was
discovered and so to me it was a fairly
uh normal idea to grow up with
um and so we've been trained in the
exoplanets from the very beginning and
so that brings
a different perspective to those who
have maybe transitioned from a different
career path
um and so I suspect with EXO moons and
probably techno signatures uh
astrobiology many of the topics which
are seen at the the fringes of what's
possible
they will all open up into becoming
mainstream one day but every there's a
lot of people who are just waiting uh
waiting for that that assuredness that
there is a secure career net ahead of
them before they commit yeah it does
seem to me that Exxon moons open
wider or open for the first time the
door to to aliens so more seriously
academically studying all right let's
let's look at like alien worlds like so
um I think it's still pretty fringe to
talk about alien life even like on Mars
and the moons and so on you're kind of
like
you know you'll be nice but imagine the
first time to discover a living organism
that's gonna change
then everybody would look like an idiot
for not focusing everything on this
because the the possibility of the
things will it's possible it might it
might be super boring it might be very
boring bacteria but even the existence
of life elsewhere yeah some I mean that
changes everything that means life is
everywhere yeah if you knew now that in
five years ten years the first life
would be discovered elsewhere you need
that in advance it would surely affect
the way you approach your entire career
as a especially someone Junior and
astronomy you would surely be like well
this is clearly going to be the
direction I have to dedicate my classes
and my training and my education towards
that direction all the new textbooks all
the yeah that's right written I mean uh
and I think there's a lot of value to
hedging like allocating some of the time
to that possibility because the kind of
Discovery will the kind of discoveries
we might get in the next few decades
um it feels what like we're on the verge
of a lot of getting a lot of really good
data and having better and better tools
that can process that data so there's
just going to be a continuous increase
of the kind of discoveries that will
open like but a slam dunk
that's hard to come by yeah I think a
lot of us are anticipating I mean we're
already seeing it to some degree with
Venus and the phosphine incident
um but we've seen it before with Bill
Clinton it's in the White House lawn
announcing life from Mars and they're
they're inevitably going to be spurious
claims or at least claims which are
um ambiguous to some degree there will
be for sure a high profile Journal like
nature or science that will one day
publish a paper saying buy a signature
discovered or something like that on
Trappist one or some other planet and
then there will be years of back and
forth in the in the literature and that
might seem frustrating but that's how
science works it's in it that's the
mechanism of science at play of people
scrutinizing the results to intense
skepticism and it's like a crucible you
know you burn away all the relevances
until whatever is left is the truth and
so you're left with this this product
which is that okay we either believe or
don't believe that by signatures are
there so there's inevitably going to be
a lot of controversy and debate and
argument about it we just have to
anticipate that and so I think
you have to basically have a thick skin
to some degree academically to dive into
that world and you're seeing that with
um with phosphine it's been uh it's it's
been uncomfortable to watch from the
outside the kind of dialogue that some
of the scientists have been having with
each other about that because
um they get a little aggressive yeah and
you can understand you can understand
why because jealousy I don't know I
that's me saying that you that's me
talking
I'm sure there's I'm sure there's some
envy and jealousy involved
um on the on the behalf of those who are
not part of the original Discovery sure
but there's also in any case just leave
you know the particular people involved
in Venus alone in any case of making a
claim of that magnitude yeah especially
life because life is pretty much one of
the biggest discoveries of all time you
can imagine scientifically
um you can see e and I'm so conscious in
myself when I get closer as I said even
the much smaller goal of setting an EXO
Moon the ego creep in
and so as a scientist we have to be so
guarded against our own egos you see the
lights in your eyes of a Nobel Prize or
yeah
um the the fame and fortune and being
Remembered in the history books and we
all
grew up in our training learning about
Newton and Einstein these Giants of the
field fireman Maxwell and you get the
idea of these individual contributions
which get immortalized for all time and
that's seductive it's why many of us
with a skill set to go into maybe
banking instead decided actually there's
something about the idea of being
immortalized and contributing towards
Society in a permanent way that is more
attractive than the financial reward of
applying my skills elsewhere so to some
degree that ego can be a benefit because
it brings in skillful people into our
field who might otherwise be tempted by
money elsewhere
but
on the other hand it the closer you get
towards when you start flirting with
that Nobel Prize in your in your eyes or
you think you're on the on the verge of
seeing something you can lose
objectivity
a very famous example this is uh Barnard
star there was a planet claimed there by
Peter Van de Camp I think it was in
1968-69 and at the time it would have
been the first ever EXO ever claimed and
um he he felt assured that this planet
was that he was actually using the
wobbling star method but using the
positions of the Stars to see them to
claim this exoplanet
it turned out that this planet was was
not there subsequent analyzes by both
dynamicists and theorists and those
looking at the instrumental data
established fairly
um unanimously that there was no way
this planet was really there but Peter
vanderkamp insisted it was there despite
overwhelming evidence that was occurring
against him
um and even to the day he died which was
I think like nine in the early 90s he
was still insisting this planet was
there even when we were starting to make
the first genuine exoplank discoveries
and even at that point I think Hubble
had even looked at that star and had
totally ruled out any possibility of
what he was talking about and so that's
a problem how do you get to a point as a
scientist where you just can't accept
anything that comes otherwise because
you're it starts out with the the dream
of Fame and then it ends in a stubborn
refusal to ever back down of course the
flip side of that
sometimes you need that to have the
strength to carry a belief against the
entire scientific community that resists
your beliefs
and so it's it's a double-edged sword
that can happen but it I guess the
distinction here is evidence yes so in
this case
the evidence was so overwhelming it
wasn't really a matter of interpretation
it was it was you had to collect you'd
observe this star with the same
um the same star but with maybe 10 even
100 times greater Precision if it
prolonged much longer periods of time
and there was just no doubt at this
point this planet was was a mirage
um and so that's why you have to be very
careful I always say don't ever name you
know my my wife and my daughter like
name this planet after me that you
discover and I can't I can't ever name a
plan after you because I'll be I won't
be objective anymore how could I ever
how could ever turn around to you and
say that plant wasn't real that I named
after you so you're somebody that talks
about and is clear in your eyes and in
your way of being that you love the
process of discovery their Joy the magic
of just uh you know uh seeing something
a new observation a new idea right
um but I guess the point is when you
have that great feeling is to then
switch on the skepticism like to start
like testing
um what does this actually mean is is
this real what are the possible uh
different interpretations that could
make this a lot less Grand than I first
imagined and yeah all so both have the
wander and the skepticism all in one
brain yeah I think the generally the
more I want something to be true the
more I inherently doubt it and I think
that just comes from you know I I grew
up
um with a religious family and was just
sort of indoctrinated to some degree
like many children are that okay that's
just normal that you know there's a
garden this is the way the world is uh
God created the Earth and then as I
became more
you know well read and illiterate of
what was happening in the world
scientifically I started to doubt and it
really just struck me that the hardest
thing to let go of when you when you do
decide not to be religious anymore and
it's not really a like a light bulb
moment but it just kind of happens over
my over sort of 11 to 13 I think for me
it was happening but it's that sadness
of letting go of this beautiful dream
which you had in your mind of eternal
life for you know for for behaving
yourself on Earth you would have this
beautiful Heaven that you could go to
and live forever and that's very
attractive and for me personally
um that was one of the things that
pulled me against it was this it's it's
like it's too good to be true and it's
very convenient that this could be
um this could be so and I have no
evidence directly in terms of a
scientific sense to support this
hypothesis and it just became uh really
difficult to reconcile my growth as a
scientist and I know some people find
that reconciliation I I have not maybe I
will one day
um but as a general guiding principle
which I think I I obtained from that
experience was that I have to be
extremely guarded about what I want to
be true because it's going to sway me to
say things which which are not true if
I'm not careful and that's the that's
not what we're trying to do as
scientists so you felt from a religious
perspective that there was a
a little bit of a gravitational field in
terms of your opinions like it was
affecting how you could be as a
scientist like as a scientific thinker
obviously you were young
yeah I I think um
I I think that's that's true that
whenever you're
whenever there's something you want to
be true it's it's the ultimate seduction
intellectually and I worry about this a
lot with um with you know UFOs and with
um it's it's true already with things
like Venus phosphine and uh searching
for astrological signals
we have to guard against this all the
way through from however we're looking
for life however we're looking for
whatever this big question is there is a
part of us I think I would love that to
be life in the universe
um I hope there is life in the universe
but
um I'm somewhat uh been on record
several times as being fairly firm about
trying to remain consciously agnostic
about that question I don't want to make
up my mind about what the answer is
before I've collected evidence to inform
that decision that's how science should
work if I already know what the answer
is then what am I doing and that's not a
scientific experiment anymore you've
already decided so what are you trying
to learn what's the point of doing the
experiment if you already know what the
answer is there's no point